hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the stafford
gambit fishing pole trap and it is a fun
one i'm calling it the fishing pole trap
because it has a lot of the same
concepts that you'll see in the fishing
pole trap itself which is something i've
done a video on in the past i'll have a
link in the description as well as at
the end of this video if you want to go
in depth in just the original fishing
pole trap this video is sponsored by
skillshare more about them later in the
video so if you're not familiar with the
fishing pole trap starts out in the rye
lopez with e4 e5 knight to f3 knight c6
bishop to b5 pretty common opening
you've probably seen the berlin defense
with knight 2 f6 and then after castle
on the king side
knight to g4 attacking this king side
here pond h3 kicking the knight back
white
is saying hey i don't really like the
knight here and black says i don't
really care we're going to play pawn h5
and you can see if there's an exchange
things get pretty crazy because this has
now opened up this h file here so if
they move the knight back things get
wild queen to h4 attacking for checkmate
that is the threat here
lots of variations in that you can
definitely check out that video but in
today's video we're going to look at how
that could play out in the staffer
gambit so staffer gamer starts out with
e4
e5 knight f3
knight to f6 and then after the knight
takes the main line is just pawn d6 and
the knight comes back f3 but in the
staffer gambit we actually play knight
c6s yeah we don't care we gave up that
pawn of material we're looking for rapid
development and a strong attack on our
opponent so after the knight takes we
take with our pawn completely opening up
for both of our bishops to get involved
into the game our queen is easily
available to get into the game as well
and now we can start our trap
from here the main line is white just
playing d3 and then we can get our
bishop involved to c5 i have another
video on the stafford game but if you're
just not familiar with the opening at
all you can definitely check that out
but you can see the bishop on c5 is
attacking the f2 square one of the
weakest squares for white early on
because it's only defended by the king
on e2 so we're going to try everything
we can to attack this king side of the
board bishop e2 makes a lot of sense
preparing to castle on the king side
anytime you feel like your opponent has
a
lead in development you want to make
sure that your king is safe so bishop e2
is the fastest way to go ahead and
castle on the king side we're gonna play
pawn h5 you can start to see the similar
setup that we have in the fishing pole
now if they decide to go ahead and
castle on the king side we can play
knight to g4 now we're gonna look at
lots of variations depending on where
they go but one of them could be to play
pawn h3 attacking our knight saying hey
we want to go ahead and kick that away
and you guessed it we are not going to
care instead we are looking to play
queen d6
and attack our opponent one thing that's
great about this line compared to just a
normal fishing pole trap is the bishop
on c5 this is pinning down this pawn on
f2 and this is definitely going to come
into play for some of the variations
we're going to look at
now you can see the immediate threat is
queen comes to h2
checkmate so we're going to look at all
the different ways that white can stop
that and how black would actually
respond then we'll look at some other
variations if they don't play this pawn
h3
early on so the first one you can see is
let's just go ahead and take the knight
on g4
in this case we're going to recapture
with our own pawn on g4
and then let's say
they have e5 really we are threatening
now the move queen 2 h2 and there's no
way for them to stop that so they could
delay it if they want to it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day it
is going to be checkmate there's no way
to stop it so that is not going to work
if they take uh our
knight we're just gonna take with our
pawn and it is a game over from there so
let's look at the next option and that
would be to play
g3
from here we can just take with our
queen
because remember this pawn on f2
is actually being pinned down so they
can't do anything they have to move to
h1 and then we can just come up here to
h2 and that is going to be checkmate now
they may not come to g3 but they don't
have a lot of other good options bishop
to f4 just delays the same setup because
now they just lose a bishop they still
have to worry about all the same threats
here they could try taking with their
bishop on g4 we're going to go and take
with our pawn and they can't recapture
our pawn because then it's just still
checkmate we have the same threats
as before so if they don't take our pawn
here
how do they continue maybe they see our
bishop on c5 recognize all the threats
and play bishop to e3 but then we play
bishop takes pawn recaptures we take
this pawn on h3
they can't really take it here because
then our just bishop swings in our queen
can get here we can completely control
this h file with our rook so maybe they
play rook to f2 here we're just gobbling
up all their pawns
if they take again bishop h3 castle on
the queen side we're throwing everything
over here and white has no real
protection in front of the king really
the best move that white has in this
original setup is a move that's not very
easy to find after this video you will
know it though and that is to play the
move e five now the first time you look
at this you may think well aren't they
just giving up a pawn and they're in the
same position but it's actually a little
bit different because after the queen
takes then the bishop can take on g4 and
black can't play the normal move and
that's pawn takes here because white
would have the move rook to
e1 and that's pinning down the queen to
the king
so because of that pin black's actually
not going to take with the pawn on g4
instead black would play bishop to g4
this attacks the queen prepares to
castle on the queen side get more
material into the attack now white can
take castle on the queen side maybe
knight two d2
getting another piece over to the king
tide to protect if now pawn g4 opening
up all the lines for the attack
threatening the move queen to h2
checkmate
white now can play queen g4 and yes if
you're like ah that queen h2 here but
this is check and so maybe black stops
the check with f5 but y can play
optimally with now knight to f3 check so
just wanted to give you an idea of how
white can play
correctly
in this position again still very
difficult for them to find all the right
moves
but yes uh because of this video you
know how to do it now a word from our
sponsor skillshare
if you're not familiar with skillshare
it's an online community where you can
pretty much take classes on any topic
that you can come up with it will look
at your interest and recommend things to
you or you can always come up here and
search stuff that you're interested in
and it will let you know all of the
classes that they have for you to take a
lot of great content on here i'm also
thinking about creating a chess course i
love the way that they lay out their
courses i think it would be pretty cool
so if you haven't checked out skillshare
what's nice is the first thousand people
to use my link in the description below
i also have it on the pinned comment
first thousand people to use that link
are going to get a free month trial of
skillshare love to know your thoughts on
it and if you think it'd be beneficial
for me to create a course on it
looking back in the trap in this
position we just looked at
white played pawn to h3 which seems like
a reasonable move we kind of talked
about how it could go poorly for white
but what if they don't play h3 what if
they just go ahead and take our knight
right here on a g4 well we're going to
take with our pawn
and let's say they look and
feel pretty safe we haven't lost any of
our pawns we don't have to worry about
this rook coming down and
checkmating with our queen and the rook
here so maybe they feel safe and played
knight to c3 but black could actually
just go ahead and sacrifice the rook on
h2
and this is really where the power of
all the threats that we have come into
play if they take with their king on h2
we're going to swing over here h4 and
this is going to be checkmate no way for
them to stop this uh we could play pawn
g3 i'm playing the optimal moves just so
you could see how they could try to
avoid it but at the end of the day
there's just no way for them to
stop it
bishop to g4
maybe knight to e2 here pawn takes on f2
check the king can't take it because
it's defended by the queen
king 2 f1 queen up here check knight
stopping it uh and now there's a couple
ways that you can actually checkmate
here it's always fun to get more than
one queen in the game so
pawn takes on g1 promotes to a queen and
this is checkmate the king can't come
here to e2 because of the bishop so that
is
one variation now if we come back maybe
the the king does not take
that rook but maybe instead they play
pawn g3
and says we really just cannot let this
queen get involved into the action so
queen can't come to h4 it is being
stopped by pawn on
g3 but now black can just play
rook to
h3 attacking this pawn on g3 remember
this pawn can't actually defend this
pawn on g3 because it's still being
pinned down by our bishop on c5 so doing
a lot of extra work
for black's
now if we come back earlier to the
opening we were looking at after bishop
to e2
we play pawn h5
preparing for them to castle and then we
play knight g4 but what if they delay
castling what if they see that
after h5 we want to play
knight to g4
and so they just play h3 and say hey
we're not going to allow you to come
over here to g4 and if you do
we can take it knowing that our king is
not over here on g1 we can just delay
our our knight moving and instead
develop our other material that we want
to get involved into the attack and that
is queen to d6
so now if they castle
we can play one of two moves one we can
stick with the same theme of
knight two g4
and this looks just like what we had
before so you kind of know what this
would look like or we have another
option in this spot we can actually play
the move
bishop takes on h3
and then if they take with their pawn
well now we have the move queen to g3
check and you can see that the pawn
is still being pinned down by our bishop
over here now after h1
the slight difference is we can't play
h2
checkmate because our knight's not here
on a g4
but we can change it up slightly things
are still going to go well for us we're
going to take here on h3
after king g1
bishop to d6 preparing to
checkmate on h2 they don't have a lot of
good ways to stop that they can delay it
a little bit pawn to e5 we take yeah hey
bishop here doesn't really matter maybe
rook to e1 give their king a little bit
of space but at the end of the day this
is going to be checkmate so they can't
really stop it we have some different
ways to attack even if they don't
castle right away just develop your
material like you have before you know
where your pieces need to be your
bishop's going to be on c5 your queen's
gonna be on d6 and you're just looking
to throw everything at the king's side
of white
thank you so much for watching the video
hopefully you enjoyed the stafford
gambit fishing pole trap as much as i do
reminder that the first thousand people
to use my link for skillshare below will
get a free month trial
to check it out also would just love
your feedback on skillshare as a
platform and if you think it would be
beneficial for me to create a course on
there so thank you again so much and
i'll see you guys in the next video